[Music]
hello YouTube chairs Levis in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
29th episode of dirty chance tricks in
this episode I'm going to show you some
of the wonderful tricks and in fact a
mini replica against other kind defense
from the white perspective the other
kind defense arises after the Mordor
efore and black responds with the move
Knight to f6 now as usual the line I
have recommended has a great surprise
value and on top of everything black has
to play very accurate moves to avoid
lots of tricks and traps here my
recommendation is you follow the main
line for a while for example ePHI Knight
to D Phi D for the main line Alekhine mu
continue with the d6 and now comes the
super surprise Bishop to c4 so white is
attacking the knight the most popular
response from the black is to play
Knight to b6 however if you open place
moves such as a 6 or c6 then I have
covered a model game in the PGN which
will give you a very good insight how to
handle such a positions ok Knight to b6
Bishop to b3 and now you can see by the
arrows black has plenty of choices
amongst them D captures Aoife is
probably the most popular response but
first we need to know what we are going
to do a black place other moose
the first more I want to consider is
Knight to c6 now as usual I'm going to
suggest something aggressive and hear my
recommendation is you continue with this
lovely pawn sacrifice a6 so white idea
is very clear white want to sacrifice
this pawn to get a tremendous initiative
as black King side will completely jam
up the first important point to notice
over here is black cannot capture this
pawn with the bishop the simple reason
is after defy black is going to lose a
piece in the opening so here the force
reply is F captures c6 afterwards why
should continue with the move Knight to
f3
so now White has a very simple plan to
play a Knight to g5 and nabbing the e6
pawn with a very good initiative so
accordingly black has three major
choices in this position
Kalli note black cannot prevent this
Knight to g5 idea the simple reason is
let's say move such as at 6 leads to the
instant disaster after the move Queen to
d3 and if King to f7 then Queen to a5
leads to the checkmate of the black game
so that's why a black has tried other
ways to interrupt our plan now the first
more I want to consider is Knight to a5
which has a clear idea to nabbing over
Bishop no matter we are going to
continue with the moon Knight to g5
attacking g6 and after Knight captures
and pawn captures black has to already
play a precise move Knight to d5 in one
blitz game my opponent tried to move g6
but to his horror he find out that after
White's next reply Queen to f3
there is no stopping on the f7 and on
top of everything black King dance will
start instantly in the opening so g6 is
not a good move in this position the
only accurate reply over here is Knight
to d5 which has the idea that if white
squint we have three then Knight to f6
cover the f7 square but here what has a
very good reply that is Knight to c3
so if allowed then white is definitely
going to take that night so black has to
play Knight to f6 and afterwards white
should continue with the move Queen to
d3 now it doesn't matter whether you
open in place g6 or c6 why it's planning
of the campaign will remain same for
example in one of my game my opponent
try the Moose c6 I castle on the Kings
side and now he played Queen to c7 but
there's a typical idea in this opening
and you should always remember this that
whenever you have sacrificed a pawn on
e6 you can more or less regain it with
the move rook - even and if it's
required then Queen can also join in to
the attack in this game my opponent
tried to desperately save his pawn so he
played the move 'if i but this is just
asking for it because after D captures
'if i D captures ePHI and the move Queen
to C for white obtained a winning
position just within fifteen Mo's the
second who I want to consider is g6
which is a very simple idea to play the
move Bishop to g7 and then castle on the
King side but once again but can play
the move Knight to g5 and now there are
two ways black and save the e6 pawn
amongst them defy is a very bad move the
simple reason is after Queen to f3 black
has a similar problem which we have seen
earlier so once again Knight to d5 is a
force response but white plan of
campaign will remain same
yep we are going to play Knight to c3
and try to dislodge this Knight here
black and tried two responses if black
capture this Knight then the simplest is
you play the move Queen to f3 and not
surprisingly enough this position gives
white a decisive advantage
for example if you open and continue
here with the moon night capped is d4
then after Queen check King to d7 pawn
captures Knight captures Bishop pawn
captures Queen to e8 Queen captures c6
check and now black response is force
black has to play King to c6 afterwards
Queen to c4 check King to d7 and now
castle on the King side we're funny
enough Black has the only piece develop
and that is awkward King the second move
Bishop to g7 is not good either
the simple reason is after Knight
captures pawn captures and Bishop
captures not only White has stopped
black to castle on the Kings side but
there's a threat on f7
which cannot be easily dealt for example
in one online game my opponent tried the
Moon Knight captures d4 but after
following sequence that is Bishop check
King to f8 c3 hitting the knight Knight
to f5 and now the very good move Queen
to b3 create some nasty problems for the
black camp now it's amazing that black
cannot play either Bishop moves or the
pawn moves because of the following
problem so let's say in the game my
opponent try the move Bishop to f6 I
responded with the move Bishop captures
g6 so there's a maid threatened on the
f7 my opponent is pointed with the MU e
6 stopping the main idea but now comes a
winning sequence that is Knight Jack
King to g7 Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes Bishop Knight takes Bishop Queen
takes Knight and now Bishop to e3 so my
opponent has to forcefully play the move
came 2 G 6 and after castle on the Queen
side white can easily launch a
devastation on this new king
the third and the final move black and
try over here is e Phi which is in fact
the most popular choices by the black
but here white can play this tricky line
that is pawn captures D Phi and now
castle on the Kings side at first sight
it looks like white is playing into the
black hand because after Bishop to g4
black is indeed threatening this ePHI
square but surprisingly enough white is
going to allow this with the MU ashtray
now if you open in place Bishop to h5 &
e6 is a very strong reply so the force
replies Bishop captures f3 and after
Queen captures f3 what can be the more
neutral than capturing this pawn and
attacking the Queen well that's right
but the following line illustrate what
kind of danger
black and faced in this line and here
why should continue with the move Queen
to e2 attacking the knight Knight to g6
and here comes White's attack with the
move rook to d1 one of my online game
with a national master continue with the
move if I I respond with the move Bishop
to e3 so there's a simple threat of
capturing the night and then capturing
upon my opponent responded with the move
c6 but this doesn't stop White's attack
because now white can't open all the
flanks with the move c4 and I think
black is completely collapsing my
opponent try the move Queen to c7 but
after pawn captures Knight captures he
was really shocked by White's next reply
rook captures d5 boom hahaha well black
doesn't have my choices he captured my
rope but then after Bishop check King to
d8 it is very obvious that something has
gone horribly wrong in the opening you
can check out the rest of the game in
the PGN
the second more I want to consider this
Bishop to a5 well against this pretty
much the same story I'm going to
recommend you should give the spawn
sacrifice with the movie six and now
black has to capture with the bishop
because if he captured with the EPP on
which is hardly played in any games why
it has a simple plan that is Knight to
f3 and you can see as I have highlighted
by the arrows White has a simple but
very effective plan of campaign so
that's why in this position Bishop
captures c6 is more or less forced and
afterwards we should exchange this
mission so once again the similar motifs
of the Knight to g5 the mainline
continue with the move Knight to c6
white shoot castle on the Kings side and
almost all the game's black follow up
with the MU g6 and Queen to d7 for
example if you play Queen to d7 then
Knight to g5 and black cannot castle so
he has to play g6 and the main line
which is g6 first and now white will
play the move Knight to g5 and in order
to save this pawn black has to play the
move Queen to d7 well here my
recommendation is you continue with the
move Queen to f3 and once again black
has a huge problem on the f7 for example
he cannot castle the simple reason is
after night to observer
White will NAB in exchange and even
though and gene suggests that the
position is slightly better for the
black but in terms of practical play it
is not easy for any human let me show
you sample line blacks obvious responses
Knight takes d4 attacking the Queen
Queen to d3 and after Bishop to g7 c3
Knight to c6 Knight captures rook rook
captures night White has a rook for
night and a two pawns which is always
going to favor white due to his extra
exchange potential
after Queen to f3 the most obvious
response from the black is to play the
Moon Knight to d8 so covering both the
square but after Knight to c3 it is very
obvious that black king will be stay in
the center hi and try now to illustrate
the plan of the campaign from the white
perspective I like to show you one of my
game against the 2100 rated player where
my opponent continued with the move at 6
hitting the night I responded with the
move Knight to h3 and after Bishop to g7
White has a very strong replied Queen to
d3
if black castles then Queen captures g6
where white get a spawn back with a very
good initiative so in the game my
opponent tried the MU King to f7 but
then comes Knight to f4 hitting the pawn
he responded with the moon g5
but after Queen check King to a fade and
the move Knight to h5 black is in a huge
trouble he decided to grab another pawn
but this is just too much because after
the following sequence that is Bishop to
e3 Bishop to f6 Knight captures pawn
captures Queen check King to g8 and now
the line opening move f4 create some
great problems for the black camp it is
founded with the move Queen to f7 but
after pawn takes Queen takes rook takes
after the whole transaction it is turn
out that white PCs are more active and
even though material-wise its equal it
is only white who is playing for the win
in this position
the thermo I want to consider is g6
which i think is the most popular choice
at the club level but after the
following sequence that is Knight to f3
Bishop to g7 and Knight to g5 already
black is having some great difficulties
in many online games my opponent
straight away fall into this trick that
is castle on the King side which is
outright blunder because after the move
a six black has a lost position within
hit lose if we exchange everything on
the e6 then white will have an exchange
and instead of that if you play moves
such as
f6 then you can put your knight
straightaway into the black guts with
the Moon Knight to f7 and after Queen to
eight and the moon defy it is a
disgusting sight for the black not only
black has to second exchange in the
later game but white has a simple plan
to play the move h4 h5 and getting on
with his wonderful attack so it's very
obvious that castle is prohibited in
this position so black has to play a
passive move such as a six but in that
case his LightSquared Bishop is already
in the prison and on top of everything
white can start his King side attack
immediately with the move Queen to f3
now once again black responds his force
black cannot castle on the Kings side
for example if he castle on the King
side then white can continue with the
Queen 23 attacking there at 7 so black
responds his force black has to play the
move at 6 but then comes Knight to e4
attacking at 6 and this is the reason
why a castle is a very bad choice King
to add several leads to the incident
disaster after the move Bishop to g5 and
after the move f6 you can take this pawn
as this Bishop cannot move due to the
devastation on at 6
so here the good reply is
kept just ePHI and after D captures ePHI
black should continue with the mu h fire
okay
no matter white will continue his piece
development with the Moon Knight to c3
and now White has a very good threat of
Bishop to g5 which black cannot ignore
it in one blitz game with a feed a
master my opponent grabbed this hot pawn
with the move Bishop captures ePHI but
then comes Bishop to g5 hitting the
Queen he responded with the Moon Queen
to d4
I played Bishop to e7 hitting the rook
and after rook to e8 I played my next
move and my opponent resigned can you
spot it I hope you find this wonderful
blow rook to d1 and bye-bye miss Queen
haha
so this game shows the potential of this
attacking set up by white after Queen to
f3 the main lines run with the move
Queen to e7 Knight to e4 d captures ePHI
and now majority of the white people has
tried the move Bishop to g5 which
doesn't create a good result for the
white but instead of that I am going to
recommend a tricky move that is d
captures ePHI now as we seen in my last
game grabbing this hot pawn is a very
risky one and I have attached a sample
line in the PGN so instead of that black
has to concentrate on his pistol of mine
with the move Knight 8 to d7 no matter
what should continue with the move
Bishop to g5 and after Queen check
Knight to c3
once again invite offers this poison
point to the black now if you open and
take this pawn in either way I have
covered a sample line in the PGN so
instead of that I should continue with
his piece development with castle on the
Kings side well so far black is doing
quite good but after White's next reply
that is Knight to f6 check I think black
has a huge problem now to illustrate the
danger in this position I like to show
you
one of my gave with an international
master where my opponent continued with
the King to a change I responded with
the move Queen to h3 he played the mu H
Phi and now I think g4 is bit risky at
this point instead of that I played a
stronger move that is castle on the
Queen side my opponent continued with
the move Knight captures ePHI but he
completely overlooked White's next
threat that is G for which at first
sight looks impossible right because
black and take the spawn and this is in
fact he did but White's idea is to play
the move Queen to h4 and now that Knight
is indeed pin and White has a simple
idea to play either f3 or ash-tree
nabbing a piece with a great attack on
the King side in the game after long
think my opponent continued with the MU
a Phi so protecting his Queen but what
he overlooked is after the move a3 this
Queen cannot stay on the 4th rank after
Queen to e7 and nightcaps as g4 white
emerge with an extra piece and attacked
a boat
last but not least what happens if you
open and play is the most popular
response that is d captures fi well
after that Y response is very obvious
what has to play this Queen to h5 move
attacking f7 now here g6 is a very bad
response the simple reason is after
Queen captures ePHI and rook to g8 like
I'd never able to castle on the Kings
side so that's why at this position the
main movie is a 6 but you can see that
with this move black light square bishop
is not going to take any aggressive
place in the game here why should
continue with the MU D captures ePHI and
now as I have highlighted by the arrows
White has a very simple but very
effective plan of campaign so in the
majority of cases no matter whatever
black plays you can stick with this plan
and obtain a very good position now to
highlight the potential of it I like to
show you this plan in the action against
most critical response by the black so
as for the online database the highest
played move against this setup is a 5
well here what should continue with the
MU a for not allowing that point to go
further and black idea is to play the
Moon Knight to a6 and put this knight on
the c v square where it can nab the
bishop pair well no matter it will not
stop of a plan because white will
continue with the move Knight to f3 and
after night 2 C Phi we are going to
continue with the move Bishop to g5
hitting the Queen Bishop d7 and now
Knight to c3 ok black execute his plan
that is Knight captures Bishop pawn
captures and now mainline continue with
the MU castle on the kingside cannon
note black cannot capture this bishop
the simple reason is after Knight
captures Queen to e7 and now Knight 287
gives white a very good position so
that's why castle is the main line move
but after that white is going to play
his last usual move that is rook to d1
and surprisingly enough this will create
a great difficulty in the black camp I
get two games in this line in the first
game my opponent try the move Queen to
d8 but after Queen to h4 I force him to
capture my bishop and after Knight takes
black has to play there another forcing
that is at six so at first sight it
looks like black has stopped every white
attack but after White's next reply that
is a knight G to e4
I think black has already a lost
position and to show you how quickly
game can finished my opponent try the
move Bishop to d7 but to his horror he
has to face this move BAM well it's a
folk so black has to take it but after
pawn takes and the move Queen captures
at six it's unavoidable checkmate he
tried the MU fi but after Queen check
King to h8 and rook to d3
he simply resigned as there is no
adequate way to stop the mate the second
move black can try over here is Bishop
to d7 but after that I should castle on
the Kings side and now my opponent who
is 2,200 plus rated continue with the
move C Phi so he wants to start
attacking on the Queen side but I think
it's too little too late
because after why it's next reply that
is rook to d3 whereas a simple threat of
rook to d1 and nabbing a piece for
example if black continue with the move
c4 then the simplest is you take this
pawn and after Knight captures rook to
d1 Knight to be six White has this
winning move Bishop to e3 and black is
going to lose a piece so considering all
this in the game my opponent try the
move f6 but this is not good either
because after pawn takes
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes
black still get the losing position
after the following sequence that is
queen capture c5 Knight to d5 Knight
takes pawn takes Queen takes check
Bishop to b6 and now Queen to B Phi
where clearly white obtained a two-point
advantage well that's it guys I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful set up
against other kind defense thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
but can you believe Black has made a
blunder yes indeed Knight to c4 haha
well sacrificing the whole piece okay I
hope you find this wonderful Blue Knight
to d6 Jack hahaha and black position is
completely crumbling